welcome back so we've been looking at
this cruise controller model for a
simple model of an automobile to
demonstrate the feedback the benefits of
feedback control in particular when our
system has some model uncertainty or if
there's some disturbances to our system
like these rolling hills that calls our
speed to increase and decrease and we
showed that closing the loop and adding
some proportional control dramatically
improves the performance over over loop
over open loop control which essentially
just inverts the plant model and
completely neglects disturbances and
model uncertainty now there are a couple
of interesting things about the
proportional closed loop model so
essentially what we did was feedback the
measurements Y and subtract them from
our reference speed R to get an error
signal epsilon and then what we did was
essentially plugged in a proportional
controller K that said u equals K times
Epsilon
but there are a couple of things that
were a little bit strange about the
example the first one is with pure
proportional control there's always
going to be some steady-state tracking
error in the controller and that's
because in the absence of disturbances
we have y equals P K over 1 plus P K
times R so no matter how large I make K
there's always going to be some slight
difference between this transfer
function and one okay we want this to
equal 1 because we want our output Y to
be exactly equal to R so we want this to
be 1 but this can never exactly equal 1
I can turn up K I can turn up the gain K
bigger and bigger and bigger and make
this closer to 1 but it's always going
to have a little bit of steady state
error Y is never going to be perfectly
equal to R and there's also some
downsides to increasing K to much we saw
this in lqr when we tried to make the
controller too aggressive
we had really jerky behavior and some
it can even drive the system unstable it
could be very fragile - any time delays
or model uncertainty and actually cause
the system to blow up okay so for a
number of reasons we don't necessarily
want to make Kay really really huge to
get Y to equal R in the car example you
also don't necessarily have complete
authority to make K as big as possible
maybe you know I may be my company more
car is not super duper responsive and I
can't just put you know gallons of gas
in the engine instantaneously okay so
there's a limit on how aggressive K can
be in reality so what we're going to do
to fix this problem of steady-state
tracking error so to fix this issue
where I have always some steady state
error is I'm also going to have another
term so this is proportional I'm going
to call this KP I'm going to add K I
times the integral of Epsilon okay so
I'm going to add my proportional and an
integral control and then I'm going to
add these two together and that's going
to give me my control signal U so this
is called a pi/4 proportional integral
control if I had a derivative term a
plus KD DDT of epsilon that would be a
PID control but we're not going to do
derivative control yet so the integral
control is extremely important to reduce
steady-state tracking error so I'm just
going to write that down integral
control the integral term reduces
steady-state error to zero okay that's
why we add an integral term so that we
don't have to jack this K up to a huge
value we can have a moderate K like K
equals 5 instead of K equals 500 and
with this integral term we can reduce
the steady-state error to exactly zero
so if there is some constant steady
state error and I'm integrating that
this integral term is getting bigger and
bigger and bigger until it closes the
gap and reduces this epsilon to zero
that's kind of a conceptual idea of how
this works so that's kind of the first
innovation we're going to talk about in
this video is
I'll put a little star next to it we're
going to add this integral control
because it reduces the steady-state
error to zero and then the other thing
we're going to do is our original model
for the plant was extremely crude and
and silly okay we said our original
model was made to pick a different color
here so our original model with
something like y equals u okay this or
maybe our model was y equals to u but
the actual car was y equals u which
basically means P just equaled one okay
P was one the transfer function was just
a unit transfer and hit the gas the
speed instantaneously jumped I hit the
brakes the speed instantaneously dropped
but we know that that's not a very good
model for what a car actually does
so the second innovation we're going to
do in this video is we're going to add
dynamics okay so we're going to modify
the system block and we're going to add
a much more realistic dynamical system
for the car and this is pretty simple so
what we're going to do is I'm going to
start writing it as a differential
equation I'm going to say a crude first
order model for a car that's a little
bit more complicated than this would be
to say I have X dot equals minus X plus
u and y equals x okay and so what this
means is that essentially Y is the speed
of the car U is like my gas and brake
and what's going to happen is there's
going to be some dynamics some some
state X which essentially accounts for
the inertia of the engine and the car
and the wheels and everything so if I
hit this with gas it's going to take a
little while for it to ramp up into the
state X which is my my speed that I'm
measuring so X is still the speed Y is
still the speed we're measuring X but
now there's this dynamic so that the
transfer function is not just a constant
y equal view there's some dynamics in
here okay
if I wanted to write this as a transfer
function this would be pretty simple so
I took the Laplace transform of both
sides of this and wrote out my normal
function I would have the Laplace
transform Y over the Laplace transform
of U equals my transfer function and I'm
going to call this p4 plant so my P
transfer function P of s is just going
to equal 1 over s plus 1 ok so I want us
to be thinking about these equivalent
representations I could represent my
system as a state space Oh de model or I
could write P as a transfer function and
instead of just being a unit transfer
there's now some dynamics because I have
a pole at s equal minus 1 and again the
solution of either of these systems is
going to be like e to the minus T
convolution with you that's what the
output dynamics are going to be ok good
so these are the two innovations we're
talking about right now we're going to
look at a fancier cruise controller
where our car actually has some dynamics
so I hit the gas and it's going to take
a while for the speed to ramp up and I'm
just going to draw what that looks like
so if I if I hit the gas this is U I
step on you now what's going to happen
is instead of Y jumpin instantaneously Y
is going to have some kind of
exponential rise to steady state ok
because this X has some exponential
dynamics X dot equals minus X so this is
much more realistic and if you have a
sports car
maybe you're maybe instead of minus one
it's minus 100 maybe it just really
jumps up to steady state value but
there's always going to be some dynamics
ok good so we're going to look at car
with dynamics and we're also going to
add an integral control term and I'm
essentially going to write down the
system we're going to solve and then
we're going to solve it in that lab ok
so let's do this now we have our control
law let's write this down our control
law is going to be u equals KP
times are - why or rather they are I can
call it our minus X or our - why it
doesn't really matter because I'm
measuring y equals x I'm just going to
say u equals kr minus X or Y it really
doesn't matter okay plus the integral of
plus ki times the integral of R minus y
and that's an integral with respect to
time okay so we're just going to be
running this integral in the error term
that's exactly what I have here u equals
KP times the error plus ki integral of
the error okay and now to actually
implement the system in MATLAB I have my
state space system for my original
dynamics X dot equals minus X plus u I
have a formula for u but now what I need
to do is I need to have some states that
keeps track of this integral of error
term and so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to introduce a new state I'm going
to say Z is going to capture this
integral of error here I'm going to say
Z dot is equal to R minus and instead of
R minus y I want R minus my state X
because I want it to be in terms of nice
states of my system because we're
measuring Y and X are the same so Z
equals R minus X this is going to if I
if I look at the integral of Z dot Z is
going to equal the integral of R minus X
so Z is going to capture this error term
Z equals this integral of error okay so
in when I simulate this I'm going to
have to keep track the integral of R
minus X I'm going to do it by
introducing another Oh de I am X dot and
also have a Z doctor
okay so I have V dot equals R minus X
and now I have u equals K times R minus
X plus K integral times Z okay I've got
a proportional gain and I've got
integral gain time Z and then
essentially I can write this this down
as a system of equations I should have
given myself a tad more room here but I
can write this down as X dot equals okay
if I if I plug this in I'm going to get
minus X now plug this in for you so I'm
going to have minus K P X plus ki z
minus K P R okay and so what we have now
is a two-state system this is our
closed-loop system X dot and Z dot X dot
is a function of X and Z so the function
of the state and now the reference is
acting like the input to my closed-loop
system right my clothes league system
the reference is the input and I had
this extra Z term because I've got to
keep track of what my integral my
integral term is doing okay so this is
going to be really simple so what we've
done is the following we've added in
some dynamics to X
we've also added in an integral term and
the way I simulate that is by keeping
track of this integral of error by
adding another state V to my
differential equation and then my X dot
V dot equations are functions of my
state X and Z and the input R and I'm
just going to write it down here to
summarize what we have so we're going to
have X and Z DDT okay so DDT of X and Z
and that's going to equal okay what is X
dot equal well its minus 1 minus KP in
the X term it's plus ki in the Z
direction ki
ok that's X and Z and what is V dot
equal this was even simpler it's just
minus X so minus 1 0 and both of these
have an input because of the reference
so the X dot it has an input of minus KP
times the reference and the Z dot has an
input
one tenth of reference okay so I'm
essentially taking these equations for
the car with dynamics and a proportional
integral controller and I'm writing the
closed loop system from R to Y in terms
of this set of differential equations
and then finally we're going to say Y is
just equal to X so it's 1 0 times X C so
I'm just going to measure the first
element of this state vector okay good
so I'm actually going to code this up in
MATLAB now so let me just get rid of
some of these extra equations that we
don't need so that we can see the plots
okay we don't need the original model
anymore because now we have a much
better car model maybe I'll leave we'll
look at this transfer function later but
just remember that this differential
equation is equivalent to this transfer
function 1 over s plus 1 ok good so now
we're going to code this up in MATLAB
and we're going to show that with these
better more realistic car dynamics and
with an integral control law I can
simulate this system for the closed loop
and I'll reduce my study state tracking
error and I'll also have more realistic
transient rise when I when I command a
new velocity it'll take some time for
the system to ramp up to that speed ok
ok so when we pull up MATLAB here good
ok so a few things what am I doing here
I am first of all going to create a car
model so I'm going to say I have a
state-space system this guy right here a
little hard to see let me see if I can
move this over for a minute good ok so
I'm taking this system right here this
is the model of my car ok so system car
is just SS the a matrix is minus 1 the B
matrix is 1 the C matrix is 1 and the B
matrix is 0 and I'm picking a
proportional KP of 5 so my proportional
gain is just going to be K equals 5 and
my proportional closed loop
system if I got rid of this integral
gain if I didn't have any integral gain
I'd have this system proportional so my
dynamic matrix would be a new a matrix
of minus 1 minus K K + 1 so kind of this
first part here and here my system okay
so that's my proportional system without
any integral term I'm going to run this
good then what I'm going to do is
essentially I'm going to take and step
the car model so I'm going to first of
all assume I didn't have any control or
no feedback control all I'm doing is I'm
just hitting the gas with a unit you
that's what step sis car does so system
car is just my my car system just P and
I'm going to step the input U so I'm
going to go from 0 gas to unit gas and
I'm going to output all of my variables
I'm going to plot them then I'm going to
take my proportional controller where I
just have KP but know integral and I'm
going to step that also I'm going to
step that system also and I'm going to
plot it okay and then finally the last
step I'm going to do is I'm going to
simulate this proportional integral
system this two-state system where I've
introduced Z which is my integral memory
term and I'm going to simulate this new
ti system this proportional integral
system so I'm going to have three plots
going on I'm going to step the car with
no control I'm going to step the car
with proportional feedback control and
I'm going to step the system with
proportional integral control which is
called system P I I'm going to step all
of them and I'm going to plot a legend
okay this should run and I get a nice
plot here let me just bring this over
here okay so this is really cool now we
see the blue curve here is what would
happen if I just step the system the
original system if I just hit the gas
this is kind of like open-loop I know
that I want to increase my speed so I
just put my foot on the gas at a
constant you know the the amount that I
we'll have at steady-state and it takes
a long time for that step to rise to one
okay now with proportional that's that's
this kind of darker orange curve here it
rises much faster to the desire to it
rises much faster but there's a big
steady-state error because remember I
chose this proportional gain to be K
equal five and so there's actually a
pretty big steady state error about
fifteen percent about one over one plus
five about one over six studies there's
about fifteen percent so much faster
rise which is what I want when I when I
say go faster I want my car to go faster
it rises faster but there's some
steady-state error that's not good
now the proportional integral controller
this yellow curve has the fast wise
because it's got that proportional term
but then it catches up and closes the
gap because I'm integrating this epsilon
constantly and so that epsilon is
integrating until it goes to zero so you
can see that the proportional integral
controller has this fast rise time and
it closes the gap so that I have a zero
steady-state tracking error and this is
what you would actually do if you were
really driving a car so if you were kind
of driving maybe like a grandmother if
you wanted to go fast maybe you just put
your foot on the gas at the final value
and you'd rise slowly but if you're like
me and you want to go faster you're
going to jam on the gas because there's
a big error if I want to go faster
there's a big error so I've got a big
proportional term I'm going to jam on
the gas and then I'm going to let the
gas up as I start to approach my speed
okay and so you can see that the P I is
much faster it exploits these dynamics
and it eventually closes the
steady-state tracking error now the last
thing that we can look at is a plot of
the control expenditure so to kind of
illustrate what I'm talking about what
the p i-- controller is doing is it's
jamming on the gas and then letting it
up as epsilon starts to get closer to
zero as my Y approaches are I'm going to
let up on the gas okay
probably not what they taught you in
driving school okay and so again we see
here our setpoint kind of our step in
you is just a step at one that's kind of
the grandmother control I'm just going
to hold the gas at one because that's my
final amount of gas that I'm going to
need so I'm just going to hold it at one
and let the system slowly rise but then
the proportional and P I say well hey if
you want to go faster there's this big
error because I'm not going faster so
I'm going to jam on the gas have a huge
value about five times as big as the
step because my KP was five and then I'm
going to let off slowly as epsilon
approaches zero as my speed approaches
the reference value I'm going to let up
the gas proportional lets it up a little
too much and P I eventually feathers
down to exactly what the setpoint should
be for for that reference tracking so
this is pretty cool okay what we have
found is that we can let up a lot on the
proportional gain and we can still have
zero steady-state tracking error by
introducing this integral control law we
can also represent that closed loop
system the closed loop system from R to
Y can be represented here just by
introducing a new state V which keeps
track of that integral term and I can
simulate the system with more realistic
car dynamics that actually take into
account the transient time when I hit on
the one from when I hit the gas to when
the car speeds up okay so it's kind of a
cute example but it gives you an idea of
the kinds of things you can do with very
simple simple proportional and integral
control laws
you could add a derivative control law
and make a PID controller which is the
most kind of common control law in fact
like your espresso machine uses PID
control to regulate the temperature and
the pressure your car uses PID control
you know for cruise control but here
we're showing that even just what P and
I we can do a great job okay
so let's think where are we going with
this we spent most of this lecture in
state space looking at Eau de
and Oh des but what we can start doing
is generalizing this P and these KS to
transfer functions so we can start
working in the frequency domain and what
we're going to do is essentially find
that we can also design a system with
good performance purely by thinking
about what we want the transfer function
of P times K to look like okay so we
have a transfer function of P it has
some dynamics but I can think about what
I want the dynamics of this to look like
for good reference tracking disturbance
rejection noise attenuation and this is
going to start giving us the ability to
think about robustness and performance
and so we're going to design controllers
in state space but then we're going to
look at their performance and design
criteria in the frequency domain with
transfer functions so it's all coming up
but this should be kind of a simple
illustrative example of you know
slightly more complex dynamics and the
need for slightly more complex
proportional and integral control terms
okay thank you